hohl mit Sarah und hat, wenn du
zu WIC kommst, ist ein deutscher veeam high - nerviges
gas nämlich reinigen
hallo objektiv was kommt hierher was kommt
austin wer als unser gesandter in versa
san francisco auf via by does not hoid
sysm own harmon smiler via durchgesickert
Gesellschaft zwischen George Begegnung
Fairness wir sind Michaans VIPs Ordinatin
Sudha verspottet von einem Deutschen auf durch diese
Meilenlücke ist so lassen sie dich negativ fühlen
und für und für Kind suchen aber in
Worten sind über Taubheit kann jede
Nebenhöhle eine positivistische Zoophilie ausstrahlen
erwähnt de  Spaß in Austin war ein
achtzigjähriges Östrogen in den USA sind
Sofia Kultur Ella Eisenboden so wenig
Positives Aktion Flug schon Fagin von
Künstler Ed tut Hype Tatsache landet morgen hoch,
was Habakuk gesperrt hat Valentine
Flöten bei der Americana-Kreistour
der deutschen Kultur Okay, jetzt ein Eskimo
Ernte jeder wird Objektiv für
erhöhte Themen über die Jahreszeiten beginnen und
Antoine
Avas Dingzi Volusia neun Stockwerke hatte D
amerikanischen Aufruf an unser Alpha t
Deutsche, also nein, eine Flagge ist weniger
Nation, jede Minute, offensichtliche Arbeit, ja, ich
in der Gesellschaft, ich bin wie ein Kreis, um
Folter zu machen, ist locker, auch das ist keine
komplexe Sache, ja, von Rias,
ja, ich nie, ich benutze Zahnseide, dass wir es getan haben.  t
und diese Linie ist als Popkultur-
Kopf von Infinity Kosovo Crunk Osgood
als anarchische Sektion und ich denke, dass
trotz ihrer Bemühungen als obiger
Punkmusikfilm ja die tausend Einträge als
Kategorie, die dann durch Interesse bestimmt wurde,
diese hinduistische Göttin Trauzeuge war
Calvin Karneval in der Konsumkultur ist jetzt
cool, mehr zu emittieren als dass Don Marquis
de Semana Amerika für die
Idee von Shawn Alphas hinterhältig monopositiv ist
und sie besitzen, dass ich in der Nähe von
Unifier Erfüllungen auf Amerika in Deutschland geklickt habe, um
zuerst als alter
Bossy zu verstoßen  Person Dish Pan zuerst eine Fanfare
Musik als nur neun gebrauchte Grunge-
Bands Kollision Episode II, die Optus
uns American Dish Musik auf 8HD Hollywood-
Film sowie
verdammt war Christian Finish und kann
ihr
c nicht im Stich lassen  Ow Burmesen, die Handschuhe, die ich schlachten werde,
und das Gaza-Pack, blutete sie mit Machops, ich
war in Bewegung, ist Emily, das Gemetzel, ist eine
Lager-T-Shirt-Krankheit, und es scheint, dass
ein Clovis fertig sang, und Frauen, es ist ish,
sein Verbraucher hydrolysierte, unbeschuhte Batman-
Besetzung für Amerika, schrie  und so ist
es im Grunde ziemlich nachdrücklich, dass ich
immer wieder
an die Indigo-Cs im Internet denke, wie am Freitag auf
dem Wasser in Deutschland, an den
Ångströms äußersten Grenzen von uns V
Thanksgiving oder dem Valentinstag
oder Halloween als neuem Verbraucher
Thanksgiving F Ironie der Konvergenz, dass
ich einem Afghanen erlauben kann, Amerika in
Kontakt zu bringen, ja,
Muda-Lebensstil, oh ja, ähm,
Diamanten als Garnitur zu zeigen, Mazel,
es ist ein Wissenschaftler, Kommissar, wird
Marcus sein, der nächste, nein, ähm, ja, ich war
da, um ein paar diesen Mann zu fragen, ja  Diese
Amerika-
Emma, also bin ich verrückt, Jäger zu sehen
, den er hat, und seinen Wunsch,
riesige Dingzi Volusia neun Stockwerke im
Americana zu kontrollieren, gefesselt an einen nach Deutschen
Java vias und Sylvia P und ein Scanner, also
habe ich einen Hasen Ferguson könnte, den
ich nicht haben könnte, eine sogar eingedrungene Versammlung, die
wächst, also wenn die Ursachen dafür ja
leichter leichter sind, ist dies ein Verbrauch der Datenpraktiken
Alice hart gekochter Ozean a  Entfernen Sie Klischees
oder Investitionen sind nicht so gutes menschliches
Fleisch, ja, ähm, es sind mehr Männer für
amerikanische Syrer nach Ihnen, ja, ja,
das ist ein enger Sohn, rotzig, ohne Zivilkleidung
Ich bin
gerade dabei, uns so zu defragmentieren, dass
es ungefähr zwei Minuten dauert.
Ich wünschte, Garten wäre Kartika angedockt, aber sein
Ärzteteam Ivan bewusster Außerirdischer springt bei einer Kokosnuss-Karotten-Reise nach Geico und weicht Zillionen aus, da
wir Netflix HBO-Rechtsteam brauchen  Sie sehen,
es macht viele Karotten Bildbesetzung, es ist ein
Selbstgefühl
Ich fühle
mich darin sehr wohl, ja, ich
habe Abends mit den Enzymen angefangen und auf dem
Draht fürs Leben.
Danke, ja, was für ein
Wissen war Englund Arlen, um, obwohl
es Phyllis Dorf ist, Alvin, um nur
England Vizekönig zu sehen, jetzt bin ich ein englischer
Anwerber  von Deutschland Harbour
Amerika bevorzugt als Angus T
Deutsch und Magnus T Americana verlassen unser
Album als die Anglin uh yeah Art von
Alice's Americans lassen Sie uns damit umgehen,
besonders Englisch nicht von seiner
Tortur einen Suchpfad freigeben und fortgeschrittenere Musik einschalten,
trans yo Alice yeah Lee
würde  Suzhou macht Vandy und mutwilligen Spaß
landet der epische AMA Toyota of Distress
und Valene Lens. Was denkst du, bist
du mit den Antworten zufrieden? Ich würde sagen
, es war gemischt, es gab einige Leute
, die positive Reaktionen hatten, einige Leute
hatten irgendwo
dazwischen und negative  Ich habe festgestellt, dass die Leute eine ehrliche Antwort zu geben scheinen,
und ja, insgesamt
glaube ich, war ich nicht so überrascht,
ja, aber einige wirklich nette Kommentare und
nette Leute  Übrigens lebst du
als Amerikanerin in Berlin, ich habe
ein bisschen Angst, dass Amerikaner nach unseren letzten
Videos denken könnten,
oh, ich gehe besser nicht nach Deutschland, es ist ein
bisschen amerikafeindlich,
wie fühlst du dich?  ein amerikaner in berlin wie
fühlt es sich an
bleib zu hause komm nicht nein ich mache scherze ähm
es ist wirklich nett die leute hier fand ich
extrem hilfreich ich bin noch nie von jemandem
negativ oder schlecht behandelt worden
weil ich vielleicht nur amerikaner bin
Weil ich ein bisschen unhöflich war oder mmm,
ich weiß nicht, vielleicht nimm das jetzt zurück. Ich bin
nie unhöflich. Ich bin immer ein netter Kerl
Haben Sie keine Angst, Ihnen zu sagen, dass Sie Ihre Füße vielleicht nicht
auf den Stuhl legen sollten oder so,
weil wir verschiedene Arten der
Kommunikation haben und die Deutschen sehr
direkt, sehr direkt sind, aber gleichzeitig
denke ich, nachdem ich hier ein Jahr gelebt habe
kommen zu respektieren, dass ich es schön finde, einen
zu haben  ehrliche Antwort und
lass dir von jemandem sagen, wie es
ist, du weißt, was denkst du, wie
siehst du den amerikanischen Einfluss auf die
deutsche Kultur? gute Frage aus meiner
persönlichen Erfahrung heraus, dass mein Freund
Deutsch spricht und ich all seine
Freunde getroffen habe, die ich finde  Viele von ihnen sind in Ich stehe
auf amerikanische Filme, amerikanische Musik und
verwenden amerikanische Ausdrücke, und es
scheint keine Negativität zu geben, sie
scheinen den Einfluss anzunehmen, und
natürlich gibt es möglicherweise Themen in der
Politik, von denen die Leute sagen, sie seien die der amerikanischen
Polizei  zu viel oder sie sind
zu sehr involviert, aber ich denke, das sage ich
als Amerikaner manchmal, aber im Allgemeinen
denke ich, dass viele Deutsche, die ich getroffen habe, eine
Vorliebe für die amerikanische Kultur
haben und sehr nett zu mir waren,
also insgesamt würde ich es tun  Sag ja, sehr
positive Erfahrung und es macht viel
Spaß, in Deutschland zu leben, danke für
diese Folge heute auf DF 1 und Z und
Leerzeilen, schreit Itsuka glücklich, ich
dulde keinen Kommentar, ich war hier von
der Folge, ah  Es war
wichtig, dass wir uns
sehr über den Austausch freuen, und wir haben
Adam, einen Spielzeugautor,
in der gemeinsamen Stadt, danke, sue, Sean, Dan
Collins, Fagott, ist meine Melodien,
ihr,
hey, dann höre ich
schnell mit einem anderen zurück  Deutscher Sprachtipp für
euch heute und das wäre in dem heutigen
Video, dass ein Typ sagte, Alice sei Americana
Sled Standish und ich würde
jetzt gerne über das Wort let's den delish sprechen, als
ich dieses Wort zum ersten Mal hörte, dachte ich, es
muss etwas damit zu tun haben  oder
schließlich, weil es aus gesegnet
und endlos zusammengesetzt ist, aber eigentlich bedeutet es oft
eher so etwas wie am Ende oder am
Ende so, dass der Typ dachte, dass
am Ende oder am Ende alles
amerikanisch ist, ich weiß nicht, hier in Bayern
scheinen sie es sicher gehalten zu haben  auf zu einer
ganz besonderen kultur das
war dein kurzer deutschsprachtipp für
heute ich wünsche dir viel
erfolg beim deutschlernen bis zum nächsten mal auf wiedersehen